patrick corbin nine career starts
against the phillies
five and two against them the wine of
the one and two on the way
swing and a line drive into left field
that's going to be a base hit
soto over towards the line a couple of
steps he'll play it on a bounce and fire
it back in and
andrew mccutchen with a good start to
the ball game four pitch walk two on for
harper
what is harper trying to bunt with two
men on nobody
out and a count of owen two i can't
believe it
one out well that tells you what he
thinks about facing patrick corbin
tonight if he squares around the butt
twice
and that is right down the middle up in
the zone
corbin gets real muto looking and
they'll face aaron nola two and two with
3.10 era
i would bet on aaron nola all the time
bouncing back ben after a rough outing
there's the curve ball and a strike
three call
and a little q shot out to center and
turner out to get it
tremendous jump and trey turner
continues to sparkle on plays like that
so juan soto back in the cleanup spot
leads off the second
[Applause]
soto launching one high and deep to left
see you later
say hey and the nets lead one nothing
on juan soto's eighth of the year
compared to willie mays and then he hits
a maze-like blast to left
how about that on cube oh we got the
triple crowd again there goes the no
hitter
there goes the shutout and now we dance
swing and miss he finally got him with a
changeup
[Applause]
here's hoskins and he swings and lifts
one of the air deep left center field
going back robles at the track at the
wall looking up it is gone
rhys hoskins has homered his third of
the season to tie the game
1-1 ball game is hoskins got a pitch up
in the zone he did not miss it and he
sends it into the philly's bullpen the
2-2 pitch all the way
strike three called on the outside
corner fastball
starts it off the plate runs it back
over the edge and robles caught looking
for the
third strikeout for nola
please this pitch is swung on grounded
to short gregorius charges fields
throws to first and he got him as
gregorius picked it knee-high and kind
of off balance still getting a lot on
that throw and turner retires for the
second half
where it goes up the middle how about
that for turner a step a throw
in two 6-3 double play
even with the runner on the move
i mean this is like old school right he
actually had to get out of the way of a
slide
that doesn't happen very often anymore
that was going to be a double play
anyway segura reached up and touched
trey turner
he'll take what the game and the pitcher
give him and that's a base on balls two
on nobody out
up the middle and enough pace to get
through cabrera coming home
he will score without a play and howie
delivers again
as he continues to hit the ball hard 2-1
nationals the one-two swing and a miss
he got him that's a big strikeout
fourth strikeout for aaron noah
one pitch to his left turner pops up and
throws a
dart to first base craig turner playing
some kind of baseball on both sides
right now yes sir
perfect throw good exchange nicely done
strike right on the money
go two pitch and a strike three calls
that's a pitcher's pitch two outs five
strikeouts three
swing and a miss on the big slider the
put them away slide
patch corbin solid through six
fastball tried to check he went around
since the home plate umpire
that's six strikeouts for aaron
look at gomes reach out two for three
nights
streaky yon goku is on the right side of
the legend
it's two of the next five hits
[Music]
go down and get it john gomez right back
up the middle
opposite way and soto can't get it it
gets by him and rolls toward the warning
track
dede is on his way to second soto will
pick it up on the track dede is going to
third
the throw is cut off and dede slides in
safely
the nationals need a big time effort
here from will harris his seventh
appearance since joining the nats
now look home against will harrison he
shoots one right past eric thames
into right field and dede will score the
tying run
it's a 2-2 ball game you very rarely see
young kids come up tom that trust
themselves and don't try and do too much
mccutchen sends one of the air to right
center field row blaze
and eaton in the gap they collide and
they drop the ball
roman stops at second base
and fortunately that ball got away from
trey turner
the phillies have first and second with
one out
like any relationship tom communication
is key
two-two ball game two outs too long and
bryce harper the battle
what always hit out towards left field
it's not deep it's gonna drop in front
of soto
roman's already halfway home and he'll
score easily the phillies have taken a
3-2 lead
and bryce harper continues to rise to
the occasion this team
needs a run he just fits this cutter off
harris
in the left field
3-2 pitch swing and a miss at a 94-mile
an hour fastball
two outs seven strikeouts for nola
here's the o2 try to check did he go
yes he did and that wraps up seven
solid innings for aaron nola eight
strikeouts overall
everybody set the one-two pitch trying
to check his swing did he go they appeal
he
and the ball game is over the curve ball
and the phillies hang on
and win it by a final score of three to
two
and congratulations to joe girardi
who becomes the 65th in baseball history
to win 1 000 games and the fourth
manager
to earn his 1 000th win as the skipper
of the fight and fills